thank you
[Music]
welcome back to a very special episode
of careful boys actually this is a
normal episode I guess because we're
about to do a very heavy article I I'm
gonna have to recuse myself as host
because this article is so serious yeah
that we can only have someone like Nick
this is not yes that decision how come
only Annette could do it because Nick is
the most serious guy here I think he's a
very strong empathy for for children so
we're just gonna let him take over
let me switch with you hey let's give it
up for Nick Nick welcome Nick welcome
Don't Clap anymore dude if you change
your name to Nick the dick if you guys
want to okay I guess dig non's still
pretty good and uh what we're gonna do
is yeah maybe hold that yeah you're
gonna have to hold these both your hands
when you do this article please that's
is that for car batteries dude yeah one
of my hands are sweaty my hands are
sweaty right let's just hold it you
could trust Ryan yeah just hold that
more moisture it's not like you're a
friend that's gonna die very serious
article okay all right hold it like this
be nervous no hold it like this hold it
like this I put on the lowest setting
first he's doing this guys you gotta
hold it like this hey you gotta like
grip it
it's blocked by this it's no it's
blocked by it's blocked put it up like
this it's not gonna I mean my boss is
yelling at me I guess it's okay you
don't have to see it you just have to
see this okay all right all right all
right guys guys serious article please
go ahead what's what's going on so um
when you guys were kids did you guys
have any uh jobs yeah yeah how old what
kind of jobs did you have as a kid
uh Target
how old are you
17.
what about you Anthony
you know it's hard because I hear the
[__] thing turn on and I'm like and
I'm like oh God and then we said 17 I
was like I forget that I might get a job
that's a sneeze from Joe so uh would you
have any jobs as a kid like where I got
paid
yeah dude I was working for my parents
at the dry cleaners after that I worked
at Knott's Berry Farm what about you
there's a clean pool
[Laughter]
I could feel that in my bone marrow what
is that how far this can't be held I
felt that on my brain can you read this
yeah what's going
pre-show banter okay this is working the
crowd all right work the ground I don't
like this this is terrible do we have a
picture of them
if we laugh we get spanked migrant child
labor found at many U.S Brands like
Cheerios Cheetos and Bart's favorite
Fruit of the Loom wait in America yeah
in America
yeah so do you guys have something
against child labor because I don't I
think you know
I think it's totally okay for kids to
have jobs but I'm assuming I'm assuming
this is bad because these these kids are
being exploited they're being isolated
I've turned it up on that one you'll be
all sweaty feel my hands feel my hands
are y'all sweating
is it only fair now that that Nick
controls it for uh I'll pay for child
labor okay sell labor that's [__]
please this is [__] oh my God this
guy here that could deal with it I don't
think that's true continue look how
[__] tough I can't handle [__]
shock things I know they're migrant
children you know so that's not good
yeah that's bad that's not good well
just because they're Mexican yeah oh are
they Mexican I think I've done
everything I hear every time I hear
child labor I think Southeast Asian kids
okay so child labor is becoming a bigger
problem as recent news God damn it has
exposed the use of it's not funny
because of the news it's funny because
I'm getting shocked and this is a setup
dude this
the child labor
are you or not no
I think he's laughing at child labor
finish the sentence I gotta take it from
the top okay keep your hands up here
child labor is becoming a bigger problem
as recent news has exposed the use of
underage workers at Hyundai
yup McDonald's
Korean a clown brand yeah and various
clown children various Ronald McDonald's
packing plants how do you guys feel
about this that's not good okay now this
is where you guys banter I think I
thought I thought we knew Hyundai was
doing child labor we did we did but now
it's gotten even worse because because
of Hyundai they've done like a
nationwide sting and they found out that
tons of places are doing it is it sounds
like you read this article I skimmed it
turned it
wait hold on switches me please switch
with you yeah
is this segment called shocking news
work whenever you turn it up that's what
he's gonna feel okay I feel bad all
right Nate put your hands on okay let's
see them hands on the table all right
continue the article Okay so
I don't know where even where to start
but how do you guys
I'm feeling it in my brain dude if I
have a brain aneurysm it's gonna be
because of you guys
I feel bad yeah you should
you piece of [__]
hey did you try the highest level yeah
yeah check it out check this out you can
even touch the highest level let's not
even do the highest level I'm not going
to die hey you pick one I feel like this
is close to child labor
check this out 12 year old roofers in
Florida and Tennessee can you believe
that 12 is not bad ah God damn it dude
it sucks that B12 and Roofing right now
in Florida it's hot right yeah it's as
hot as [__] the person here with a child
wouldn't you want taika to start working
to be honest if the kid is willing and
the parents are willing
um I I wouldn't mind child labor I
actually think it's you probably have a
lot more benefit than a lot of times
even going to school because I remember
when I first started even like making my
own money
what happened uh nothing I'm just like
when I first started making my own money
I think my self-esteem started going up
uh-huh because I felt like I was
actually doing something like productive
and constructive oh you know it's crazy
how you could tell a story versus you're
just sitting in class the whole time and
you're like oh this is so [__] boring
how am I ever gonna apply this [__] to
[__] real life but if you're actually
working in real life and building a
house like Roofing is kind of fun is it
cool yeah what about when the beaming
Sun of Florida
it could have been during September it's
nice and cool is it though yeah when's
hurricane season
I don't know I don't study hurricanes is
there much roofing during hurricanes
I don't study a hurricane okay so check
us out it's not not only are they
Roofing but they're also under
in Delaware Mississippi North Carolina
so and also which is not good for
anybody really especially children
because they're growing
what are you doing is children working
in The Dakotas overnight shifts oh [__]
so that's the thing for me it's about if
the kids are willing and the parents are
willing and they're in a place yeah
where it's not gonna stunt their growth
or development so kids no way Jose so
kids
oh
hey that's not funny
that's not me okay so kids they need to
sleep and develop and all that and if if
it's going against that I don't like it
so you're okay with child labor as long
as it doesn't affect their growth
and if their parents are they're not
getting exploited so for example like a
coal mining child they're gonna have
lung cancer by the time they're 15.
because for example a lot of people that
are really successful entrepreneurs
business owners whatever they
technically have done child labor all of
them because they grew up because they
grew up in that middle yeah yeah like
Henry Ford's kids or whoever they grew
up in there doing little things here and
there being productive so by the time
like like what was that fool's that
[__] Warren Buffett by the time he's
like 12 he's already trading at a
different level than most adults are
okay but I want to challenge you here
Bart tell me yeah I'm just kidding but
keep your hands on your hips
okay I think that issue is not children
getting work experience but it's the
problem of them being subjected to
unsafe working if it's exploitation I
don't like because these there's in this
article here they're saying in Grand
Rapids spicy dust from immense batches
of flaming hot Cheetos hold on dude I
feel like your name you're listening I'm
listening
I want closer with Cheetos
hey if you're a kid wouldn't you want to
work at the flaming hot Cheeto factory
[__] yeah yeah you hold one with me why
the [__] would I do that hey can you
work like that or do you have to hold on
no hold up hold on hold the middle hold
the middle just hold it I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna hurt you
just keep reading all right whoa that
was hard dude see he's the big meanie
you're the mean that's you cause you
only had these two fingers on it that
was so nice come on finish the article
with them in your head don't don't
continue without holding them you got
one yeah
[Laughter]
okay boys okay and I feel like you're
derailing this right now I'm sitting
here to talk about it closer with you
but unsafe work conditions exploitation
[__] like yeah getting [__] up lungs
oh that's flaming hot Cheeto dust yeah
that's very sad sad
but this one doesn't sound as bad but
it's still probably bad for the kids um
but in comparison they're saying that
these kids are moving heavy pallets of
cereal that make their backs ache okay
that's crazy as a kid though wouldn't
you want to work at a cereal factory all
that flaming hot Factory you think it's
like Willy Wonka right but then it's
like when you're there it's actually not
true because you just your co-workers
are ex-cons and [__] and it's not really
Oompa Loompas but also people are
working with I think these American
companies are turning a blind eye
because these kids are migrant workers
yeah I mean so that's the issue and they
don't qualify for the same rights no or
like same uh like health care or like
emergency services or whatever
potentially it's so wrong though for
that to happen even though they don't
legally you know most these kids are
from Central America oh and this is as
this says exploded in 2021. so how do
you guys feel about that can do you
support this can yeah I do not support
it well but we need to interview the
kids because what if the kids like hey I
[__] love it I get to make some money
I get free flaming hot Cheetos we don't
know how the kid feels yeah we don't
know man I wanted to that's true I
wanted a child labor myself and it was
illegal
but how about uh
[Laughter]
that's what a mosquito feels like dude
that one hurt
flaming hot Cheeto duster it feels like
in Asia and a zapper it's been an
episode of shocking news hey I think we
should end with the with the national
anthem would you please lead us of your
heart I'm not dude it's too close to my
heart I'm gonna die both of us both of
you guys both you guys please
ready okay not too hard okay Ryan I
won't turn it down ready
oh it doesn't work
[Music]
thank you
let's cry
I just want to see if it broke
still works you guys we're gonna hear it
first still work